Hello everybody, Dr. Connors here. I'm going to show you how you would take the
P220
right machine from Attilia Robin out of the box. We're going to send it to you in a box
plastic wrapped bubble wrapped also with it. It's going to be a computer
It also with it will be the bulb now. You can purchase a
Footpath apparatus for it. You can purchase a scanner apparatus for it
But we're not even simple because most people are using the bulb program using it overnight and using it during the day time
So when you get it you obviously have to plug in the computer
So it's going to come with a cord to plug in the power of the computer
It can't go anywhere else. So you can't make a mistake
This doesn't plug into the right machine and then it comes with a cord that you have to use to plug in
the right machine
To the computer so they can talk to each other
It can't plug in anywhere else. It plugs in right back here and then it plugs in to the USB port of the computer
You can't mess that up. It doesn't go reverse. It doesn't go any other way
It doesn't go in any other port. So pretty easy there. And of course it comes with a plug to power the machine
So you have a plug that powers the machine. Again, this doesn't go anywhere else. You can't mess this up
We always suggest that you plug the oh, let's into a
Either a grounded outlet and better would be into one of these strips like we have on the floor here that is
That is a transistor in there and a surge protector
So if you get a lot of light need storms where you're at you're going to have some surge protection
So you don't get any electricity flowing back and damaging your unit
Now the unit is quite simple, right?
It's it has a power button on and off
We always suggest you don't turn the machine on tell you get the ball plugged in and you got this all connected
So I have this connected back here when I just showed you now. We want to connect the bulb
Typically we're going to be including with your package an overnight tube
So it'll look like this or something like this and it's simply a ball
That's the plasma tube and this one is a crystal tube not everybody will get a crystal tube
But this is a crystal tube and it's encased in proxy glass. That's the whole idea
The treatment benefit of a right machine comes through this not through this. Well, it's ending the frequencies to this
But this is the treatment part. So you want this bulb as close to you as you possibly can
So if you're using this at night, we suggest that you snuggle with the bulb underneath the covers
Now you're going to see in a second when I run a program during the day with this light
You're not even going to be able to see this light up and some people running it for the first time during the day
We're like, I write that working. It's not lighting up
Well, if you put a blanket over it and you put it in the dark you'd see that it is lit up
Now we don't want this to keep it you awake at night. So we suggest you put it under your covers right up next to you
And then the machine itself does have a light but the only light on this machine isn't the auto of switch
And you certainly can put a piece of black tape over this auto switch
There's literally no light coming from the machine
Now, it's pretty easy on how to plug this in because red goes to red and black goes to black
And all you do is push those cords in and you're done. The only other thing you have to know is do you switch this to auxiliary?
Am I running a foot bath? No, I'm running the bulb. I'm running the tube. So I switch it to two
That's all you need to do. Oh, we need to turn it on
So that's the only light that you have again
You can put a piece of black tape over that if you have this on your bedside
You don't want that light even a little light like that could be bright at night, so we don't want that
People say well, you're gonna have the light of the computer. Well, I'll show you in a second. You're not going to
Well, when you first get your computer
It's going to look like this. What's going on? It's turning on so push the on button and
It's going to power up like this
Now I always suggest now I try to remember to send the computer to you in airplane mode
Airplane mode means that it's not going to try to pick up the internet
You don't want to use this computer on the internet. You want it completely dedicated to your right machine
You don't want it to be tried to download Microsoft programs or things like that or downloading things that could mess up things on your computer. So
You're gonna have a screen that looks something like this. You just click on it then you'll get to this log in
There's no password. CC just stands for Connors clinic. You'll hit side in and you're side in
This is the home screen of the computer
So you can change the picture if you want but quite honestly
I don't want you on this very much because you're gonna open up the program. This is the Atelier Robin P220 software
It's a great big A there pretty easy double click on it and then you're going to open up the program
So open up the program, but it'll always open to the last program you had running though
I had
Running all cybers frequencies. I don't want to write that. Let's let's look at something else. So I clicked on let's do that again
So I'll show you I clicked on open program. So open program brings me back to the home screen of all the programs that are in your
computer. So remember the computer contains the programs. It sends the information via this cord to the right machine to send it to
Put out those frequencies via that plasma tube to your body. So those light frequencies are going through your body to affect your body
So these are the programs you're gonna have a whole bunch of different file folders that I've created that will say Conner's Clinic file file for all sorts of different things
And then you'll have
alphabetical listings of the individual programs. So it starts with abdominal inflammation and you can see if I go to the scroll bar
It's scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll. Oh boy. There's lots of them. There's
You know 2,000 programs all set and done that you could possibly pick from but let's go to I don't know let's go to
Parasites roundworms. There we go. I say I think I have parasites. I think I have roadworms flatworms
There's a pro multiple programs for roundworms. This is roundworms flatworms. Let's click on that double click on that. It opens up the program
And then you can hit
Run so once you hit run. It's sending the program
via this cable
To the machine you could hear a little sound depending on what frequency is running
It'll sound a little bit different. Some will sound a little louder
Some will sound a little quieter and then you'll see the frequencies come out the ball
Now again in this light do you see any frequencies come out the ball? Oh boy
Barely because it's so bright out, but put this in a closed closet. You'll see the frequencies come out
You're running this at night and it will be lit up not horribly, but it will light up different
Degrees of light depending on what frequency you're running. I don't want that to keep you awake
Put it under your covers. Snuggle with the bulb. That's the whole idea
We want you running these overnight programs
So you're getting more frequencies for a greater amount of time
That's going to be the key to using right. It's not a magic wand
It's just going to heal you in an hour use. You have to run these frequencies for a period of time
So again plugged in to the machine. You're taking this bulb to bed with you stuggling with it and bed
I always put mine by my side like this the benefit of this is if you roll over
It's a couple feet away from here. You're still getting adequate treatment
So this is a great bulb to use again. It's encased in plastic so you can't break it drop it on the floor
It won't break and we have very little problems with any of these bulbs very little problems with this machine
So you're going to love it
You won't love it. If you don't use it though, so make sure you're
Utilizing this machine running the programs that I've created for you or running any other programs for you or your children or grandchildren
That you think that they might be coming down with something or dealing with something
I always think using right technology is your first go to then you go to nutrition and supplements and herbs and then if that doesn't work
You might have to go to